tiger woods opening up for the first  time since that devastating car crash  that happened nine months ago woods had  been speeding near los angeles when he  lost control of his car triggering a  violent rollover leaving him with some  very serious injuries in his first  interview since the crash woods admitted  he nearly lost his leg he says he hopes  to heal to play golf with his 12 year  old son charlie but  he says his days as a full-time  tournament pro are over  i can still maybe if my leg gets good  enough maybe click cook off a tournament  here or there  but as far as climbing the mountain will  get all the way to the top  i don't think that's a realistic  expectation of me  wood says he's not even at the halfway  point in his recovery